for monetary policy I think that
structure works and has served us well I
think the bank of England of course
thinks about the cost to the public
purse of decisions that they make but
they also have to think about their
policy objective which is to make sure
that there is access to credit for
British companies and that there is a
there is a macroeconomic environment
that is bearing down on inflation and
that's their job
so in that context I've asked to be kept
fully informed but I also recognize that
this is something that is not the
central banks are taking different
approaches at the behest of their
government
so if you Commission
I've asked to understand exactly what is
happening but within the boundaries of
the fact that the bank of England is
independent and I think it's important
that I respect those boundaries because
I think that regulatory framework has
served us well
and at the moment you don't have clear
sight as to how that 133 billion pounds
that the office for Budget
responsibility has plonked in their
their publication would be financed well
I have
um obviously seen the obr's numbers uh I
haven't seen treasury analysis as to
whether they agree with those numbers or
not because the obr is also independent
but what I have seen is that the
um the the purchases that are happening
this October will happen this October
and due to happen this January which
people have been concerned about a
potential 11 billion loss as far as the
October sale is concerned it was less
than a billion and in the context of 120
billion going the other way I think it's
you know important to look at the whole
picture
could I just add chair just on this
point of um how they will be paid for so
the 133 billion I think is a figure
which has already incorporated into the
forecast in terms of the forecast for
debt interest costs and for the change
in the level of public sector net debt
so in a sense the Autumn statement is
delivering the Chancellor's fiscal rules
with that with that forecast reflected
although I think as the ABR say in the
document and I think said in their
evidence to you yesterday is very
uncertain because the biggest driver of
um the forecast is the difference
between bank rate and the interest rate
that the government is paying on the
debt that is now held by the bank
um which was bought obviously over a
period of years from from
2008 right so it's very particularly
uncertain because it's the the movements
between those two different two
different rates it's it's a niche issue
but it's very substantive in terms of
the numbers so that's why I wanted to
raise it but I now want to turn to the
um 2019 Manifesto
um on which Hugh Chancellor elected on
which I was elected and um and
colleagues on this committee were the
conservative ones were elected because
the Prime Minister has made uh it um
emphatically a number of times the point
that uh he wants to stick to that
Manifesto as much as possible
um we've obviously already breached the
manifesto commitment to the world's
poorest and
um I wondered if uh you could talk about
the other Manifesto commitment that I
think was broken in the Autumn statement
which is the commitment that you won't
have to sell your house to pay for care
can you talk about your thinking around
that
um well it's obviously an area that I am
very familiar with for my time as health
secretary and indeed as chair of the
Health and Social care Select Committee
and I want to say straight up that I
support the dill not reforms I think
that
um they
make a very big difference to a certain
category of family who are affected by
what are called catastrophic care costs
normally a a neurological condition that
means that someone is incapacitated for
a very long time has very high cost of
their care being delivered
and so I was Keen to proceed with those
reforms
um but I also looked at the overall
pressures in local government the
overall pressures in the social care
system and the pressures in the NHS
and the pressures in the NHS have been
particularly exacerbated by something
that wasn't the case when we made those
Manifesto commitments which is
a once in a century pandemic which has
put extreme pressure on the NHS
and as a result of that
the NHS has seven million people on its
waiting list that's their own estimate
and I don't think we can make progress
in bringing that numbers that number
down
if around 13 and a half thousand NHS
beds are occupied by people who should
be being looked after in the community
so the difficult decision I took
was to put nearly five billion pounds of
extra spending capacity into the social
care system
of which about a third of the cost comes
from delaying the implementation of the
dill not reforms and I decided that was
going to give the most direct help to
people in need of Health and Care over
the next two years oh you accept that it
was a breach of the manifesto pledge but
you had to make difficult decisions
that's effectively what I'm hearing can
I turn to another
um you're trying to if I may say
um you know it was I think a delay in
implementing a Manifesto Pledge on the
basis of the extreme circumstances we
had with a pandemic and I think given
that that the result of that along with
extra money coming from the treasury and
extra support from local councils
is a nearly 5 billion pound increase in
the social care budget which is I think
from memory around 200 000 additional
care packages I think that was the
balanced decision to take in the
circumstances but by putting it off
until after the next
necessarily do run the risk that it's
never implemented well
um
I understand people might have those
concerns I should also say that local
authorities themselves we received a
number of representations saying that
they didn't feel that they were ready to
implement it ahead of the next election
and
I I do think that there is a very
extreme situation facing the NHS and
care system and it was important to take
action pretty decisively in the Autumn
statement
Manifesto commitment was not to raise
the rates of income tax now you haven't
raised the rates of income tax unless
you're making between 125 000 and 150
000 was that a footnote in the manifesto
oh um
the the basic rates of income tax have
not been raised the thresholds have been
raised and the Threshold at which you
pay the 45 B rate has been reduced
dramatically
and I don't think I made any
any attempt whatsoever to hide in the
Autumn statement that this was 25
billion pounds of tax Rises because it
was a package of tax Rises and spending
cuts and I was very open about that if
you ask me why I didn't choose to raise
headline rates of Taxation that's
because I Believe In cutting taxes as a
conservative and I want to bring those
headline rates down over time and I
decided that although it's there's an
element of symbolism it's actually
important symbolism that I want to bring
those rates down and that's why I
decided that it was better to do it
through the thresholds okay
couple of other quick questions
um have you allocated enough to the home
office and the NHS to allow those other
Manifesto commitments about the 20 000
more police the 40 new hospitals and the
50 000 additional nurses and the the the
other commitments along those lines is
there enough money in the system to
achieve those Manifesto objectives well
there are pressures on all government
departments because of inflation that
wasn't expected and we are going through
a process of working through with all
government departments how they're going
to manage those pressures but with the
home office in particular
um the uh even after the decisions in
the Autumn statements their annual
increase in budget is going to or their
budget is going to increase by 3.1
percent in real terms every year of this
Parliament so they've seen a substantial
increase the ministry of justice is near
a four percent
okay thanks
um turning to Capital budgets um just
two very quick questions on that first
of all
um in terms of an explicit commitment
you made to hs2 and delivering that up
to Manchester and keeping that Capital
commitment in the budget
were you able to have a look at the
policy exchange report that suggested
that most of the benefits would come
from doing although common to Birmingham
was that something that you looked at or
that um you know because there are
obviously colleagues who aren't
particularly happy about the capital
spending being allocated to hs2 well I
um
decided to proceed with hs2 to
Manchester for two reasons
firstly because we have a long had in
this country infrastructure that is
inferior to peer countries uh with
respect to both our Rail and our road
Network and I think if we want to be the
most prosperous economy in Europe
we have to sort out these problems and I
still think we've got profound
difficulties in the way we execute large
infrastructure projects and I think it's
something we need to come back to as a
country but my other reason is because I
think that our failure to have good
National infrastructure is one of the
key reasons why we have such large
Regional imbalances in wealth and you
know if you look at
our country we have a much greater
concentration of wealth and high living
standards in London and the southeast
relative to other parts of the country
as compared to countries like Germany
and one of the ways that you deal with
that is by having good transport links
that mean that if you want to benefit
from those higher standards of living
you don't have to move down to London
you can stay living
up north and you can travel easily to
other parts of the country when you need
to so I think having good
connections between our countries is one
of the central ways in which we spread
wealth and opportunity across the
country within Capital spending I speak
as a representative of a constituency
that's quite flood prone along the river
seven are you maintaining the capital
commitment to flood defenses
we are going through all our Capital
commitments now uh what I managed to do
it was a big priority for me in deciding
the Autumn statement
to avoid Cuts in spending that would
damage future growth
I think protecting people from floods
isn't is an important thing to do
because of the damage to economic growth
if people are flooded
but we aren't specifically making
commitments to individual areas until
we've been through that process what I
managed to do was to protect Capital
spend broadly at its current levels in
cash terms
um but we aren't increasing it by as
much as we were planning to do that
means it's still going to continue
at around double the level it was a
decade ago which I think is very
important given what I was talking about
earlier
um and we want to do as many of the
major projects as we can and certainly
all the ones that are strategic to our
growth plans
Chancellor please note my interest in
the capital spending on flood defenses
uh Danny thank you chair uh Arthur and
Johnson can I ask you about the fiscal
rules so we've now got our I think sixth
Set uh since since 2010. what do you
think the real value of having fiscal
rules is at all and how can we have a
confidence in these latest ones
well um
the point about the structures we have
is that people want to know
some basic truths about our approach to
Public's finances that we understand
that in the end you can't spend money
you haven't got
and that we are a country that is going
to repay our debts
and the purpose of the structures we
have
is to allow the chance to the exchequer
to make commitments
and then the independent obr
assesses whether those are credible and
true
so we do change our fiscal rules
chancellors do change fiscal rules from
time to time
I think that it is reasonable to change
the time period at which our fiscals
operate from three years to five years
given that we're dealing with
a once in a century pandemic and uh
energy crisis that is the biggest since
the 1970s
um but I think people still want to know
that there is a serious intention to
reduce our debt
um and so that's why I think it is
important to have for schools okay thank
you I mean it is helpful to have them
because it means that we can hold you to
account uh for the trajectory you're on
um but they're very tight these the
rules were now said with a particularly
with the Headroom that the OVR said
you've got nine billion pounds and it's
all predicated on stable interest rates
and falling energy costs
we had the abrn yesterday and we were
asking them why they are so confident
that energy costs are going to fall over
the course of the next year because if
they don't it's going to be very
difficult to meet the uh to meet the
rules and to uh and to do what you're
saying so can you explain to us why you
are confident uh that the uh the energy
costs are going to come down so
dramatically
as they need to in order for the uh for
the rules to be met
well I think we have to accept that in a
period of massive Global instability
there is uncertainty in any forecast
um and the obr
has as good a record as anyone normally
their forecasts are broadly in the
middle of the pack of of all the
economic forecasters
um but they're very open about the fact
that there's a range of outcomes the
Headroom in the final year is only 10
point is 9.1 billion so it's you're
absolutely right it's very small
and um I think what we have to do is to
if we're going to be sensible about this
have a central scenario based on our
best guess of what's going to happen to
Energy prices
um produce a set of accounts that's
based on that
but recognize that when it comes to the
spring budget when it comes to next
year's Autumn statement these things may
change
okay well let me can I just put to you
what you would do in in that scenario so
if if you don't have the money that
you'll think you're going to have at the
moment
you know already our taxes are at the
highest since the second world war are
deaths at the highest since the second
world war it feels inconceivable that we
could increase either of those
substantially so the only change that is
feasible is spending reductions do you
accept that that is indeed the path we
would have to be on if we didn't meet
the expectations that have been set out
this month well I think I appreciate you
have amazing spending reductions but
still spending is rising over the course
of the the Autumn statement period
is that sustainable I think it's
difficult to predict how you would react
in a hypothetical situation it's not
just a sort of politician trying to duck
hypothetical answers but I think it is
genuinely difficult
um if the forecasts moved against us if
if you know Energy prices went up again
um if there was a
a big hole in our accounts I think
depending on the challenge you face your
your reaction might be different but I
don't think it's sensible to speculate
exactly what you would do because you
don't exactly know what the problem
will be and I just think you have to be
honest with people and say the situation
might change
and your response might have to change
but on the basis of the facts as they
appear to now and they appear to be most
likely I think we have a good plan the
right plan brings down inflation shows
that we can balance our books and repay
our debts but we have to be honest with
people that things can change in the
wrong direction
okay nice John you had a quick question
on this I'm going to a few questions
that I made but very quickly Chancellor
first of all good afternoon and can I
just say thanks for sharing um you know
the compassionate side with regards to
your Autumn statement by maintaining the
link with
inflation
um accepting the low pay commission
recommendations but also the business of
the triple Mark in a way staying with
the um fiscal targets um I sense from
the Autumn statement you also share my
skeptism and indeed members around this
in this committee about the value of
forecasting
um you have to you have to attach a
certain
um importance to them but you know as
Galbraith said you know forecasting
economic forecasting is is only there to
make
um you know um astrology look
respectable
um where do you in in making your
um estimates and suggesting your targets
within the treasury where do you go with
regards to the forecast is it mostly the
obr is it the is it the bank of England
or is it a treasury unit or a
combination of the three
um well obviously
I listened very carefully to the bank's
forecasts and the obr's forecasts but
I think my observation would be that
there's only one thing worse than a
forecast and that's not having a
forecast and I think it is really
important as a discipline even though
you're aware of
the likely inaccuracy of any forecast
I think your starting point has to be
what is most likely to happen on the
basis of the information we have now but
you have to be you have to recognize
that there's a fan of outcomes if you
visualize what the graphs look like and
there's a sensitivity in the analysis
but
um there's less sensitivity if I can put
it this way Mr Baron in the overall
direction of travel I think we can know
from the forecast that we have from the
obr and the bank of England that we are
likely to be in recession
that we are likely to be spending more
on energy that we are likely to be faced
with uh an increasing tax bill and more
pressure on public spending and so even
if you don't know exactly what that
pressure is
you can react to the direction of travel
and broadly prepare the country prepare
people
for the fact that there are some
difficult decisions that you have to do
you know does it not worry you a little
bit you say we're you know those
forecasts there's a broad consensus but
I don't remember a time and I was
working in the city before I came into
politics where there's been so much
disparity in the official forecasts I
mean for example you know the obr is
forecasting overall growth of two and a
half percent between 22 and 25 and yet
the bank of England is projecting a
shrinkage of two percent
um if it raises interest rates that the
market expects or at least a shrinkage
of half a percent if they stay where
they are I mean that is a big disparity
um when you're trying to project targets
whether they be fiscal or not isn't it
it is but I think both of those still
the overall picture
is a period where it's going to be much
more difficult for the government to
raise the kinds of sums of money that
it's used to raising and therefore we
have to be responsible with our finances
and the single biggest thing we can do
to reduce the pressure on public
finances is to Bear down an inflation
because so many of our costs as a
government are index linked and I would
just say if you look in the near term
so I think a lot of concern people had
about those forecasts was
you know are you going to embark on a
big consolidation when actually the
forecast might be wrong I think in the
near term what the obr say is that the
measures that I announced on Thursday
make the recession shallower make the
increase in unemployment less by about
70
000 and so you know in the near term I'm
confident that we're doing the right
thing final question if I may I mean you
you will perhaps understand the
skepticism within the committee or
certain members of the committee when it
comes to the track record of of
forecasting
um you know there is clear evidence that
forecasts have been inaccurate in the
past you know initially inflation wasn't
a problem then when uh but did despite
clear evidence of that then when it
became a problem clearly evident it was
going to be transitory then it was going
to fall away I mean there's a
picture here that doesn't Inspire
confidence going forward
is does the treasury to what extent does
the treasury actually undertaking its
own
in-depth research as to say for example
the drivers of inflation medium-term
drivers such as you know short business
supply lines aging demographics
climate change disruption in in order to
try to improve the accuracy of forecasts
going forward because this is an
important area to try and get right as
much as possible
well I I agree with that
um I would say that the correct response
to the inaccuracy of forecasts
is to try and make them more accurate
not to fly blind and in defense of the
OVR their forecasting record has been
more accurate than the record of the
treasury that was doing those forecasts
before the obr existed I think it is
important for
ministers to take their own views they
look at forecast by other organizations
they take their own view my judgment is
uh that
you know looking at the range of
forecasts
a consolidation in our national finances
was necessary to bring down inflation
which is the number one threat to
stability in the economy and that's why
I took the decisions I did but I would
be very honest with people there are a
range of outcomes none of us know what's
going to happen next in Ukraine and
therefore none of us know what's going
to happen to International Energy prices
and we have to be honest that uh that
uncertainty means that decisions may
change in either direction in the future
okay thank you
thank you good afternoon Chancellor uh
just to be clear it's not a unanimous
view the skepticism about obr
forecasting so Mr Maron is uh doesn't uh
we don't share we don't all share his
views just to be clear
um so so Chancellor that you've been you
you've obviously been focused on
stabilizing the economy after what
happened in February in part because the
chancellor your predecessor and the
former prime minister chose to fly blind
and make announcements uh economic
announcements uh without an OVR forecast
so I just want to take you back to where
we are at the moment the oecd has warned
that the UK will be the lowest have the
lowest growth among the big Group of
Seven industrial countries next year
only Russia facing sanctions from the
West over its attack on Ukraine will
perform worse the obr has reported that
living standards will fall by seven
percent over the next two years and the
gov governor of the bank of England to
this committee and elsewhere has said
mentioned the differences between the UK
and Eurozone
Eurozone growth rates are 2.1 percent
U.S growth rate 4.2 percent yet the UK
economy is 0.7 smaller than at the start
of the pandemic and by just finish off
uh by 2024 people's disposable incomes
will be will have gone back to 2013
levels and we are likely to see by 2027
and 28
third of people's disposable income
being reduced per capita
so we've seen all of this happen over a
number of years but particularly over
the last over those crucial few months
credibility issues our credibility on
the line internationally and somebody
described I forget who it is that the
British people are paying a moral
premium a [ __ ] premium not a moral
premium a [ __ ] premium is being paid by
the British public what's the point of
having the conservatives in government
with that Legacy Chancellor well and I
appreciate you've inherited a poison
chalice but on behalf of your government
over the last 12 years perhaps you can
explain to the British public what the
point is of your party in government
well I'm going to answer that question
in a less party political way than it
was asked because you can take well for
12 years with respect Sally will you let
me answer your question because I would
like to give you a proper answer
you can take a snapshot of economic
statistics to tell you any story you
like so you can look at this year's
growth and the UK is the fastest in the
G7 you can look at next year's and we're
one of the slowest According to some
projections if you take if you say
what's the long what's the point of my
party I would say Well since we've been
in office in 2012 we have the third
highest growth in the G7 which is
something since 2010. we have the third
highest thank you for that chair we have
the third highest growth in the G7 and
that is over a period when we've had
three Global shocks to contend with the
financial crisis the pandemic and the
energy crisis and so I think that's a
record
that we can defend very comfortably if
you look at more recent but longer
period of time the oecd report that you
talked about says that since 2020
we have had the fastest of any G7
country the fastest recovery from the
pandemic
but I think there are some very big
economic challenges we face that are not
related necessarily to those shocks and
I am very keen to address those so I am
concerned that employment is still from
memory 334
000 lower than pre-pandemic when in a
number of our peer countries employment
levels are back to what they were
pre-pandemic that's why I asked Mel
stride the
work and pension secretary or he's doing
a review in fact for the prime minister
to look at the issue of Workforce
participation there are many issues that
relate to that you know the way the
benefit system worked Child Care
Arrangements the decision to retire
early and he's he's doing that I think
we've got some long-term issues over
productivity
that's why in my awesome statement I
spent some time talking about the skills
challenges we face
um where I think we've had a lot of
initiatives but there's still a lot of
progress to make so I don't for one
second say that there isn't a lot of
work to be done but I don't agree with
your overall suggestion that over the
period of time that my party has been in
office uh we haven't grown uh
impressively given the challenges we
face
uh we'll we'll agree to disagree uh can
I take you on to uh the obr figures that
state that between by 2024 to 25 the tax
burden will be at its highest level
since the second world war can you talk
us through what the impact of such a
high tax burden will be on economic
growth
well I'm very concerned that if taxes
are too high it makes it difficult to be
a modern dynamic economy and I'm
concerned about the effect on incentives
and I am a conservative who believes you
should bring taxes down so if you look
at what the obr said uh two of the
biggest
drivers of that increasing cost are debt
interest payments which are now 120
billion pounds a year that's
around double the entire budget of the
ministry of Defense
that's a massive increase from around 40
billion from memory down before the
pandemic so that's one of the big things
and the other big thing is Health and
Care costs where the Aging populations
had led to a surge in growth what do we
do to bring those tax rates down and I
think from memory I think the forecast
projections show that taxes are
proportion of GDP goes down from 47 to
43 over the forecast period but what do
we do first of all on debt interest the
key thing is to bring down inflation
Bear Down on interest rates or support
the bank of England so that they can
bear down on interest rates to reduce
those debt repayments and bring down our
debt levels and that's one of the most
important reasons why we announced that
difficult consolidation when it comes to
the NHS I think the answer is real
public service reform because I think
the British people want a good strong
NHS they want to know that every penny
is being spent wisely and that's why but
we invited Patricia Hewitt to review the
way the new integrated care boards work
which are the new structures that are
going to determine how the NHS is run to
make sure that we can reduce the
micromanagement and targets which I
happen to believe drive a lot of the
inefficiency and really Empower local
decision making and better use of every
pound we spend so can I just on health
then since you brought it up there are
seven million people waiting about 117
000 people have died while waiting for
treatment
uh do you do you believe that the
changes and then we've got 400 000
people who are economically inactive one
of our Witnesses said two days ago that
that could be a hit of about 0.7 on
economic output that's pretty serious do
you believe that the investment you're
putting in and these reforms that you're
proposing whatever they may be
uh that's going to be able to bring
people back into the economy those who
are willing to work who are not active
because of health issues can you can you
give us an assurance that that's going
to happen and by when do you do we
expect given your expertise in health
health care both as former Health
secretary as well as Select Community
chair can we see those groups because
that has a bearing on migration as well
if we want to keep migration down
well that that is why we put uh eight
billion pound package is it going to
happen though are we going to be able to
get those people who are in economically
and active with that investment well
that is sorry just to start to answer
again that is the purpose of putting in
eight billion pounds a year in a context
Where You Are consolidating by 55
billion pounds in tax Rises and spending
cuts to to choose to put eight billion
pounds into the NHS and social care
system is to say you're prepared to have
eight billion more of cuts elsewhere or
eight billion of tax Rises elsewhere to
fund it but we think it's the right
thing to do yes because first of all we
are absolutely committed to the NHS and
we want to have first class Health and
Care in this country and we think that's
what voters want but secondly absolutely
because the NHS has a crucial role in
helping
get people better and get people back
into the workforce unfortunately the the
voters aren't getting the first class
health care that they deserve and it's
good to hear that you are you are taking
your health expertise into the truth I
mean uh they are not getting it uh
people are not getting GPS appointments
they're not getting seen for their
treatment you know about the cases
you've seen it over the years in the as
chair of the select committee so as the
returns about it as well on this Annie
but what I would say is that uh yes of
course there are major challenges the
NHS is facing but I think it did it
saying it's good question
I think it's important to recognize the
NHS did an absolutely fantastic job in
the pandemic
um and uh they are having to recover
from the biggest external shock to their
services in the history of the NHS
candid compliment Chancellor that it's
good that you're in the
child health background one final
question the resolution Foundation has
said that since the pandemic the net
result that is that long total long-term
spending plans are largely unchanged
since the start of the pandemic leaving
the consolidation entirely driven by tax
Rises are you comfortable with that
um
a consolidation
was a combination of tax Rises
what I announced in the Autumn statement
I think increases tax as a proportion of
GDP by about one percent
and reductions in planned spending to a
long-term rate of around one percent in
real terms a year it was planned to go
up by much more than that now I think
that's going to put pressure on spending
because we know in areas like the NHS
it's highly unlikely that you'll be able
to contain the growth and spending at
one percent so I I don't pretend this
isn't anything but going to be
challenging but we are absolutely
committed to public services and that's
why we took the decision to find extra
money for schools and extra money for
the NHS
to make sure that they are protected
through the worst of a difficult period
thanks rishinara Anthony uh thank you
chair so I think we all agree across the
house and across the party uh that we
need more economic growth uh your
predecessor and his growth plan he
obviously prioritized growth at all
costs didn't work out uh in your uh
Autumn statements you've prioritized
balancing the books first
um but in the obr projects that overall
growth will be two and a half percent
between 20 to 225 so less than one
percent years we go into recession and
then out of it um is that good enough
I think we need a long-term growth rate
that is
closer to three percent than two percent
um but to get there is going to take uh
a combination of short-term support to
help the economy weather the recession
and that's why the measures that we
announced on Thursday I think do that
they reduce the peak to trough
reduction in GDP from about three
percent to 2.1 percent
so I think that's important but also
some structural changes and I think the
structural changes uh revolve in a lot
of areas that I touched on in the Autumn
statement but in terms of investing in
people I think the skills the education
and skills agenda is so important which
is why Michael Barber's doing his review
on whether we're achieving our
objectives on skills why we put the
extra money into schools but also we
need to look at the leveling up agenda
and how we are better at spreading
wealth throughout the country and that's
why it was important to me to protect
key infrastructure projects which is one
element of of leveling up a very major
factor for our long-term economic growth
is going to be a stable source of cheap
green energy and so proceeding with size
well our national Energy Efficiency
ambition are all part of making sure
energy doesn't become a
energy Supply doesn't become a shadow
hanging over firms making them hesitate
as to to whether to invest
um but then perhaps most important I
talked about you know a long-term plan
for the UK to become the world's next
Silicon Valley and I think we have a
huge brexit opportunity to set our own
regulations in areas like life sciences
and technology and AI Gene editing so
that we can meet the UK the must go to
destination for all the research all the
embryo companies
that want to invest in these very
exciting areas that are going to
determine the future so it's a mixture
of short-term and long-term yeah I'm
wrong for the most as you mentioned
they're worth a long term and indeed you
did talk about them in the Autumn
statements but in terms of the actual
measures in the Autumn statement the OVR
has analyzed the impact on uh growth on
the supply side and concluded that the
less effect of the new measures on
potential output is neutral over the
forecast period because things like that
they not going ahead of the Health and
Social care Levy encourage more people
to go into the labor market without
freezing the tax thresholds uh reduces
that uh the annual investment allowance
keeping it a million pounds encourages
more business investment but then some
of the changes in r d scheme reduce
business investment overall they just
said it's it's neutral on growth do you
think they're being too pessimistic
I think a lot of supply side measures
which I very strongly support because I
think doing things to improve the
productive potential of our economy is
what a good conservative government does
um
do take a while I mean you know
economic growth this is over forecast
period which is yeah but I mean you know
if I give you an example the average
economic growth rate in the 1980s when
we had all the Thatcher supply side
reforms was not that much higher than
the average growth in the 1970s
but actually the benefits of those
supply-side reforms really showed in the
decades that followed when Margaret
Thatcher wasn't prime minister I that's
not a reason not to do them ultimately
if we want to be a highly prosperous
High skill high-wage economy then we
have to be much better at making sure
all our people have really good skills
in the modern economy that's a big
agenda I want to make sure we progress
on that and you know I want to attract
investment from all over the world in
high growth industries but that's a
process that I recognize I can make a
start on but isn't going to come to
fruition until long after I've gone
the chancellor when he the Prime
Minister when he was doing your job he
gave the May's lecture where he uh
identified like many people that are
long-term economic problem is low
productivity but he in particular said
uh the solution to that is having higher
business Investments uh but actually
business investment has in in the UK has
is no higher according to the these obr
forecasts will be no higher in 2025 than
it was in 2016 so it's actually some
scroll up and down a bit but basically
flat over over a decade
um are you disappointed with that
performance and what what can be done to
get business I mean I assume you agree
with your boss's analysis on business
investment uh what can be done to get up
but my boss is absolutely right uh to
talk about business investment
um I I do absolutely believe that
um
so um my priority in the Autumn
statement was not to do anything that
would make it go in the wrong direction
so the bit that I control as Chancellor
is public investment and that
principally is around infrastructure and
that's why it was a priority you also
have control over tax policy which
affects business Investments as well
that's true but my priority in the
awesome statement
uh given the lack of available funding
for big tax breaks to encourage business
investment which in ordinary
circumstances would be a priority for me
um the priority was to avoid cutting cap
capital projects or the capital budget
in other way that would be detrimental
to our long-term investment in the
productive potential of the economy so I
think I succeeded in avoiding the big
cuts to Capital which often the first
place people go when they're looking for
Savings in a hurry I think that was
important but is there more to be done
to encourage business investment
absolutely how are you going to
encourage more business investment well
I think there are lots of things you can
do first of all you have to make sure
that your tax system is competitive and
you do as much as you're able to do at
any one time to make it competitive but
you can also do things like setting out
long-term plans for growth industries
like life sciences technology green
Industries
that attracts people to come to the UK
because you know we're using our brexit
freedoms to allow things to happen uh
with our uh with forward-looking
regulatory structures that you can't do
in other countries
um so you know I look at uh
as I talked about in the Autumn
statement I look at Nigel Lawson's Big
Bang in 1986. that wasn't something that
cost the government any money but
far-reaching regulatory changes
attracted enormous investment into UK
Financial Services in the years that
followed that because there was more
competition more Innovation it was
possible to do more things here and I
think that's
that demonstrates that you can do very
very good things even if you don't have
money to spend
um obviously you have in this Autumn
statement put taxes up and you need to
balance the books and taxes are going up
to the highest level for 70 years as my
colleague talked about but do you accept
you also describe yourself as a low tax
conservatives so presumably you accept
the longer term Beyond this Autumn
statement you'll need in part of
encouraging economic growth we'll be
getting taxes down absolutely and um and
I think that includes business taxes as
well
but we absolutely want to do that I just
didn't feel in a context of raising
taxes by 25 billion
people would really welcome long-term
promises to reduce taxes because we
weren't going in that direction in that
budget but I I do absolutely believe
that if you want to have the right
culture around Enterprise if you want
the dynamism that encourages
entrepreneurs and small companies to get
off the ground then having a tax burden
in particular uh
reducing the taxes that people have to
pay before they've made a Penny's profit
those can be very very beneficial
one thing that hasn't been much
commented on you you reverse the the
cutting the basic rate of income tax or
the promise cut which the chance the
Prime Minister had promised in a couple
of years and you're predecessor forwards
and you've now canceled it I think
um is are you concerned about the impact
that would have on work incentives and
so on
well
my belief in the importance of work
incentives is why I would consider
myself a conservative who wants to bring
down taxes
um but in this situation that was one of
a number of extremely difficult
decisions that I had to take
um overall I decided that the balance
should be shared broadly evenly between
tax cuts and reductions in spending when
it comes to spending it was mainly
reductions in planned growth in spending
but there will be some real Cuts in
spending too
and broadly I tried to balance business
taxes and personal taxes but
um these were very very difficult
decisions I don't pretend otherwise
finally the the approved says I had a
target for how much she wanted to get
growth up to and you said in your first
answer you prefer gross closer to three
percent or two percent I think is what
you put it do you believe in having a
growth Target it's not something
governments UK governments have
traditionally done
I'm not sure whether it's a value to
have a growth Target because I think
it's really difficult if you talk about
all the measures that we've been talking
about it's very difficult to know
precisely what impact
they will have cumulatively and what the
time scale is
um but do I agree with the central
Insight of my predecessor that the only
way we're going to square the circle of
paying for decent public services and
being a competitive low tax economy is
increasing our growth rate he was
absolutely right to say that
have lots more questions but no more
time thank you Chancellor thank you very
much Anthony Siobhan did you want to
come in now because I know you've got to
say thank you chair that's really really
kind yeah and Chancellor in advance of
your Autumn statement you said that
those with the broadest shoulders will
bear the heaviest burden and we on that
side with this side including I hope
Andrea would agree with that and I've
searched high and low through your
statement but I can't seem to find the
section on those with the broadest
shoulders of all the non-doms how much
would closing the tax loophole for the
super rich raise for the public purse
well I've asked the treasury to look
into that but my let me say that my
concern is
um I think
the labor party claiming that it might
raise three and a half billion is that
the number that uh Springs I think
you'll find it's not just the late party
the London School of Economics have
assessed it as a 3.2 billion the ifs
have said 3 billion and I think Warwick
Business School had 3.6 billion or are
these people not reputable people who
you should accept their assessments I've
I've asked for that to be looked at my
point was different actually it is that
I understand that
non-doms pay in tax uh all the taxes
that they do pay around 8 billion pounds
of tax a year so
um I want to make sure that wealthy
foreigners pay as much tax in this
country as possible Ireland has a
non-dom regime France has a non-dom
regime
these are people who are highly mobile
and I want to make sure that we don't do
anything that inadvertently loses us
more money than we raise yeah yes but we
already know that the London School of
economics has done precisely that piece
of work with anonymized data from hmrc
and they assess that a hundred non-doms
would leave the UK
um if that loophole was closed that's
not exactly a huge Exodus is it well I
want to be sure that there are no
Dynamic effects that mean that we lose
more income than we gain and if I could
point out that you know I think
if you look at the budget as a whole we
very much did deliver on that commitment
that asks people with the broader
shoulders to Bear the heaviest burden if
you look at what we did with the 45p tax
rate tax rate pairs if you look at what
we did on income tax as a whole
um
how the we know how the non-dom double
whammy works so if you don't pay tax in
the UK on your money that you earn
abroad as long as you don't spend it in
the UK so actually we're getting hit
twice we're not getting the tax and
we're not getting the spend how does it
make any sense to carry on in that way
we are getting a lot of spent because as
I understand it the spends that we get
brings in about eight billion pounds a
year which is a lot and I just want to
make sure that anything you do
in terms of the non-dome tax regime
doesn't mean that you lose more than you
gain and this is a really interesting
concept isn't it when it comes to the
super rich we always want to give
concessions whether it's the non-dom tax
loophole whether it's charitable status
for private schools whether it's the
lifting the cap on Bankers bonuses so
incentives for the rich and
responsibility for the police Sergeant
the senior award system or the school
head of year who will be brought into
higher tax bans through your Frozen
thresholds isn't it the case there's one
rule for the rich and another rule for
everybody else no and I do understand
the picture you're trying to paint but
if I could just say it is Internet it's
real I'm just saying if you'd let me
answer very kindly I understand the
picture you're trying to paint but it is
180 degrees wrong look at what we did in
that Autumn statement we increased taxes
on wealthier people but when it came to
poorer people we are could you possibly
let me finish if you could let me finish
I will well I'll let you answer ask the
question so I think it's reasonable you
should let me answer it we increase
taxes on the wealthiest when it came to
the poorest people you can see we
upgraded benefits by inflation that's an
11 billion pound commitment we respected
the triple lock which reaches a lot of
pensioners on low incomes uh we have a
very generous energy price guarantee
about 900 pounds per household
um 500 pounds next year and 900 pound
payment for everyone on means tested
benefits there was a huge range of
measures which means the most vulnerable
people in our society when you add up
the increase in the National living wage
the benefits operate
the cancellation of the Health and
Social care Levy the support with fuel
duty this is thousands of pounds going
to some of the poorest people in the
country and I think that reflects our
values as a nation but at the same time
as doing all of that
I believe that it was very important
that we avoided doing things that might
be politically charged but would have
been damaging to our long-term growth
and my concern about what you're
proposing on non-doms is that it would
cost us more money than it would make us
you know that the research suggests that
it wouldn't 3 .2 billion pounds midwives
nurses Primary School breakfast clubs I
think I know what side of the Divide I'm
on I think I know what side of the
Divide I'm on because midwives nurses
all got a lot of extra money for the NHS
people in schools there was a big
increase in funding for schools people
on low income there was a huge amount of
effort to make sure we help people
through a very difficult time and when
it comes to measures on wealthier people
that we know will actually increase the
money coming into the treasury we took
those measures where we weren't sure if
it was damaging to economic growth we
held back and for very good reason
thank you Siobhan and Chancellor I think
you have published a distributional
impact overall on households and perhaps
you want to just refer to where that's
published
um I think it's published in the Autumn
statement it's uh it's a separate
document that's published alongside
which does does show that the measures
announced um in the Autumn statement are
progressive with the top decile paying
uh the most certainly in cash terms and
uh more uh than I think it's quite hard
to read the diamonds but um is is very
Progressive
yeah it's the impact on households the
distributional analysis accompanying the
awesome statement
thank you very much thank you Siobhan
Emma thank you chair after in terms of
I'd be super grateful if you're able to
give quality but short
um
Quality but short please because I've
just I've just got a few
um you'll be aware that there are
serious concerns about falling real pay
across the public sector and while the
pay review bodies have responsibility
for recommending pay awards for many
public sector workers the Reema is
Guided by affordability which is as
defined by Guidance received by the
treasury it would be therefore helpful
to know at this point what provision
you've made for public sector pay growth
in the departmental settlements that you
set out in the Autumn statement
that's a process that's ongoing with
departments at the moment so I can't
give you an answer
when you made your Autumn state
departmental spending you allocated put
aside recognizing that there would be
public sector pay growth we always uh
make uh allocations recognizing what pay
awards are likely to be I just don't
know what those numbers are are at the
moment because we've had this very big
growth in inflation recently and so
we're having to work through all those
numbers
the wisdom but you're just not sure what
there is at the moment no we're going
through a process to work out what those
numbers should be given the recent peak
in inflation
the number of public sector workers are
considering industrial action at the
moment and this is obviously as a result
of the cost of living crisis and the
difficulty many of them are finding and
making work pay will you agree to meet
with the unions to discuss their pay
issues in the public sector and
understand the pressure that members are
under
well the um responsibility for engaging
with unions which I I strongly encourage
rests with the relevant sector of State
I know for example in health Steve
Barkley's been engaging very frequently
with
um the RCN and I think that is very
important and I think we recognize as a
government that there are real pressures
on people's spending power caused by
inflation and what we have to do is to
respect the prb process because that's
fair and it's independent and often when
I was Health secretary they would rule
in a way that was very very difficult
for the NHS budgets but at the same time
not do anything that means that the
inflation problem that we have gets
worse and stays for longer would you as
Chancellor at least meet with the TUC or
some of the representatives just to hear
from Members personally about the
difficulties they're facing I'm very
happy to meet with the head of do you
see thank you very much and the Autumn
statement obviously froze income tax uh
thresholds do you know how many more
people now are going to be paying income
tax because of that freeze
I don't have the number in front of me
but I can certainly write to you and let
you know thank you would you be also
able to have him writing or let me know
how many families will see their tax
child credit withdrawn because of that
freezing income happily do so thank you
on tax hopefully we'll all agree chair
that getting people to pay what they owe
is a good thing
um so I just want to look at looking
back at the Autumn statement you
allocated a further 79 million over the
next five years to hmrc in order to
tackle tax fraud which works out 15.8
million a year the department for work
and pensions is set to receive an extra
280 million between now and 2024 to
tackle fraud error and debt in the
benefit system which works out at 112
million pounds a year and the government
have calculated that over the course of
five years this 79 million pound hmrc
investment sees a return of
725 million that's an investment gain of
4 646 million which as a percentage is a
return of
818 return on investment in tax fraud so
Chancellor what was the reasoning behind
the decision to allocate more money to
benefits fraud which has a lower yield
and less money to tax world when it has
a much higher yield
um we want to Stamp Out All fraud
wherever it is because there shouldn't
be any at all and we allocate money
based on what uh the relevant department
whether it's DWP or whether it's hmrc
say they need to bring down fraud in
their areas now
um in the case of DWP it is a a more
intensive process with on average on
average smaller sums of money but it is
whether it's fraud we should stamp it
out and I think that applies in all
areas of government spending I totally
agree with the decision to stamp up
forward my point was if you tackle tax
fraud you get a 818 return which is much
higher than tackling benefit forward but
more money went into tackling benefit
for these taxes so just to reassure you
there is no ideology in this if hmrc
said that they could get the same again
with the same money again they would get
it we want that money so although just
to add the figures for how much we get
are things which the AVR scrutinize and
obviously we always try and persuade
them that we can you know if if we
invest make additional Investments we'll
be able to achieve more in terms of hmrc
uh collecting more tax
um or DWP uh preventing more fraud But
ultimately that is one of the
constraints in the the there is a there
is a point at which they say well the
additional money will not get additional
yield or okay so so there is a sort of
obr process that we have to go through
here as well to recognize the revenue
last month during a public account
committee oral evidence session Jim uh
Harbor the head of hmrc said I quote on
average for every pound that we spend in
our customer compliance group we recover
about 18 pounds worth of additional tax
revenues he said that in the Public
Accounts committee that for every pound
he can get 40 18 pounds back and tax
watch have found hmrc estimates that in
2020 to 21 32 billion pounds of tax went
on collected 45 of that is a result of
Fraud and Tax Works believe that these
numbers are certainly an underestimate
so
why only give 79 million when the head
of the hmrc is saying for every pound
you give me I can get 18 pounds back
when we've got all these problems with
budgets we've got departmental Cuts
we've got public sector uh potentially
not getting the pay rise they need why
not give more money to tackle tax fraud
well if you're trying to suggest that we
have not done everything we possibly can
to reduce tax fraud then I'm afraid
that's mistaken we are cracking down
with hmrc we're cracking down the DWP on
benefits fraud the costs of doing so are
different in different sectors but we
assess each case on the basis of how
much money they need to do the job and
that's why those numbers are what they
are
I wasn't suggesting that I was quoting
from the head of the hmrc who said on
average for every pound we spend in our
customer compliance we would cover about
18 pounds and when a government is
looking for additional money it seems a
little nonsensical to put more money
into lower yield in benefits fraud and
not put more money into tax form and
that generates so much more income for
the government well um that's why he got
an extra 79 million pounds and I hope he
maintains that 18 to 1 ratio and if he
can do even better then I'll obviously
consider giving him even more money
because I think it's very very important
that we do that he would welcome that
and I'm just finally uh chair thank you
the obr forecasts a cumulative 7.1
percent fall in real disposable
household income over 21 22 to 23 24
which is by some way the largest on
record I do recognize that the energy
price guarantee and cost of living
payments reduce that fall by about a
quarter but is a fall in household
disposable incomes inevitable
well I think when you look at the what
the obr themselves say in terms of the
three Global shocks that we've been
dealing with in the last 15 years but
two Global shocks in the last three
years then
unfortunately it's not particularly
surprising that you see a fallen
disposable income and I think it's our
responsibility as a government to do
everything we can to help people through
a difficult patch which is why yes they
say that we reduce that fall in living
standards by a quarter but the thing
that is actually more important is that
over the next year we reduce it by a
half which is the time that I think
people are going to be in the most
difficulty because that's the forecast
recession period And I think that is
what we should be doing as a government
to do everything we can to cushion
people through difficult times
which I accept but how can a fiscal
policy that reduces health or incomes be
justified in a cost of living crisis
well it's that isn't our fiscal policy
if you remember the obr said that the
measures I took in the Autumn statement
reduced the impact of the recession uh
by a full one percent of GDP
um saved 70 000 jobs so we have acted to
help people through a very difficult
period could I just add on that I mean
there are two other things I would say
one is is the biggest driver as the ABR
says is the the rising Energy prices and
because we're a net importer of energy
that is a kind of cost to the economy
and the the figures that they present
are economy-wide figures within that
though of course the decisions that were
made in the Autumn statement affected
how the distribution of that average
Fallen household disposable income was
shared as demonstrated in the
distributional analysis so that what the
government could do through the policy
was to change where some of that burden
fell and skew that more towards the
higher income deciles and provide more
support at the bottom so that's an
average rather than the specific income
by income hit thank you thank you very
much Dan and uh I'm Marie I think you're
next chair
the support on energy bills was very
welcome albeit generally at a lower
level and certainly uh what you've done
for specific Health to vulnerable groups
but I think commentators have observed
that there are two particular problems
because the extra support is linked to
means tested benefits it means that
about 40 of lower income families who
are not on benefits don't get bored and
the second comment uh which commentators
have raised is that the the way the 900
pounds
um support effectively uh works if
you're on Universal Credit
um then you get the lot if you are one
pound the wrong way then you don't
um it might be fairer or perhaps better
to spread it so that that test are you
or I not eligible comes in different
tranches rather than one off and
hopefully you'll tell me that maybe that
is your proposal and I think the other
concern we have is the unintended
consequence of linking this benefit
to Universal Credit so there's a
disincentive to work more hours which
will take you outside if you like that
that cut off which means you will lose
quite considerable sum of money
I recognize those concerns and I don't
think it's the right if we have these
higher energy prices uh for the long
term
if they're here to stay we've been
talking about the forecast before then I
don't think doing that support through
the benefits system is the optimal way
of doing it I would point out of course
that you can work on Universal Credit
so by targeting it on people on
Universal Credit you are not
you are not just targeting it on
people who are out of work absolutely um
but um I do recognize the point you make
I think the challenge we had
or have is that if we want to help
people quickly the benefit system is a
way that we can do that we we know who
everyone is we have a good idea of their
circumstances the people who were
helping through the benefit system
so it is an efficient way to get people
help quickly but what I said in my
comments in the Autumn statement is that
whilst we'll be using that system this
year and next year from April 24 we want
to work towards a social tariff or
social discount approach
whereby we reach all people equally on
low incomes that means a lot of
complicated work to marry the
information held by hmrc with the
information held by DWP on benefits
and that's a very big operational
challenge but that's the direction of
travel we want to go so might that also
impact your thinking on the pensioner
benefit which currently is universal
and one of the things that the obr makes
very clear is that the affordability of
all of this depends very much on what
actually happens to energy prices and
they suggested that this particular
scheme
um you know in a scenario could cost
another 71 million and they give a
scenario in terms of where Energy prices
might land up and I think there's two
concerns one is where would you find the
extra money but two if I think about
householders if that happens do you
still stand by the guarantee and the
scheme the specific support scheme
you've put in place to the that to the
time to the deadline that you currently
set so people aren't concerned uh as to
what might happen if Energy prices go up
during the next couple of years well as
things stand you're absolutely right to
point to the
um the high cost it's probably going to
cost around 80 billion this year and uh
possibly around half that next year and
we do stand behind what we've offered we
think it's very important that we give
people security that what we promised we
will deliver
but
um
in the long run we're going to need
everyone to help us crack this problem
if we're not going to have a huge
additional
burden on taxpayers which ultimately
will lead to the kind of high taxes that
um I certainly don't believe are
desirable in the long run going forward
and so what we're really saying is that
we will always be there to help poorer
households
the way we do it will change and that's
why we talk about the social tariff or a
social discount
but for most people we need you to play
your part in reducing our energy
dependency on what Putin chooses to do
in Ukraine and that's why we've got this
National ambition to reduce energy
consumption by 15 the EU ambition is 13
we're a couple of percent higher but
other countries are doing the same kind
of thing and that isn't just at a
national level but that's for every
household and we think that
the 500 pounds that we're offering
to help people save next year at
powering gas prices if people do the 15
they could save that 500 pounds
themselves in the amount they pay in the
years that follow so we're trying to
help people to help themselves we're
giving them a cushion this year and next
but we do need people to change their
behavior and with regard to businesses I
think he said they would be a more
targeted approach now I appreciate I
don't expect you to tell us today what
that's going to be but I'd like to
understand what do you mean by targeted
and what sort of criteria are you
looking at because their support is much
more limited and a number of them have
ended into some fairly
difficult fixed term contract at very
high rates well I would say that
um you know limited is perhaps not the
right word to use to describe the
support we're giving businesses this
year it's probably going to cost about
18 billion pounds which is huge support
for businesses and we will have a scheme
that is generous next year not on that
scale but we will have generous support
for businesses next year and we're going
through the process of how that's going
to work but we are particularly thinking
about businesses that might be
vulnerable to those high prices so
smaller businesses in particular and
also larger businesses in energy
intensive in histories so we're in the
process of Designing that we want to
design it as quickly as we can it just
wasn't possible to do it in time for
last Thursday
there's a one final
cut uh price contracts that both
individuals and businesses have entered
into they've entered into them some of
them at the peak for two to five years
they are tied into them and if you like
the whole Autumn statement and the obr
commentary assumes that energy prices
will come down in 24 25 and while the
wholesale price is coming down uh the
retail price clearly because energy
companies have bought bought ahead is
not and we may well find that that those
who have entered into five-year fixed
sound contracts are very heavily
penalized is there anything that you
could do might you think about doing to
help those people traps from no fault of
their own who entered in to fix some
contracts because that was the only way
they could then qualify for the
government support
well we um I don't think as a government
we can be in the business of second
guessing the the decisions that people
make with their own individual energy
suppliers but what we can do is say
we're going to help you this year with a
two and a half thousand pound cap we can
help you next year with a three thousand
pound cap we're going to help you
conserve the energy you use and for the
poorest people we'll try and find
a more effective structure than we're
able to do at short notice
to help them going forward but we are
saying to people that in the end
everyone is going to have to take
responsibility for their energy bills
and they're going to have to think about
how they reduce their energy consumption
because it is a national mission to make
sure that we can't be blackmailed by
people like Putin when they do things
that interrupt International Energy
supplies and you know we've done
extremely well as a country to get up to
40 of our supply through Renewables and
nuclear and we announced a very big
investment in nuclear at the Autumn
statement with sizewell C so there's a
long-term process to make sure that we
have permanent cheap green supply of
energy which is very very important for
everyone but as we get there we're going
to need everyone's help
in my final comment answer would be
I think you need to recognize for some
people that energy bills have gone up
from hundreds of pounds do tens of
thousands of pounds some of my
businesses have come with many hundred
percent plus increases that is the sort
of Bill it will take out one of my
businesses it will take out 25 percent
of all of their of their profit that's
unsustainable so with respect I think
there are some very specific issues
around these fixed price contracts which
I do think the government has some
responsibility because that was part of
the the term to get the benefit the
government offered to look at them to
look at what they might be able to do
working with the suppliers the energy
companies to bring some sort of sense to
what would be a very perverse
consequence if the energy companies
actually came out of this actually
making a lot of money on the backs of
people who could in afford it but if
you'd like to write with me write to me
with the details of that I'm very happy
looking to it as we construct our
package for next year thank you
appreciate it thank you Anne-Marie thank
you very much and and to Ann Marie's
question about the 900 pounds we took
evidence I think it's from the
resolution Foundation saying that it
would be better to spread that 900
pounds into smaller payments is that
something you're planning to do or will
it be a binary you get the 900 and then
the next day you don't no so I think the
the intention
um and this will be for DWP to set out
like the one-off payments this year
where they were um the 650 pounds was
made in two two separate payments with
two different eligibility dates
recognizing the fact that people move in
and out of Eligibility as they claim or
move off Universal Credit for example so
um we we haven't specified we haven't
well I think that is a decision yet to
be making we haven't made it and I think
we'll discussions on that set out but it
definitely I I I don't think it will be
one payment me thanks so much Alison
thank you very much chair and just to
pick up on when I'm really left off Tory
Glenn community base a Community Hall my
constituency are seeing their gas bill
go up from 9 700 pounds to 62 000 pounds
they can't afford that and I would urge
you to consider them within uh what
you're looking at for energy bills
absolutely but they are the people that
we're helping this year with our uh with
our energy price guarantee 18 billion
pounds of support across the country so
it's very very significant help and we
will be giving very significant help
next year but if you're saying we need
to think hard about the long-term impact
then I absolutely agree
thank you um can I ask about the Energy
Efficiency plans that you had in the
statement why is this six billion pounds
and new funding for Energy Efficiency
only going to be available from 2025.
because we're spending uh I think it's
6.6 billion pounds in this Parliament up
until that point and I decided this was
very important to extend the program and
also because I was advised that there
are very severe supply chain constraints
with things like the supply of cavity
wall insulation and solar panels and so
the right way to boost the supply of and
deal with those supply chain constraints
is to Stage the investment
I mean it's not much of a national
Mission if you have to wait three years
for it well you'll that would be the
case if we weren't spending any money
now but we are
could I just add the other thing that
was announced in the growth plan in is
proceeding is an exchequer funded
increase in the Eco scheme which is
where the energy suppliers do the sorry
um uh do the the insulation measures
themselves all the Energy Efficiency
measures themselves so there was an
additional billion over the next couple
of years
um funded by the exchequeror Via energy
companies
the cheat of the environmental audit
committee has said that the numerous
schemes can be confusing to Consumers to
know what they're eligible for and the
start stop start approach programs over
the years has bruised industry and that
talks to some of the supply chain issues
actually that you're finding the
industry hasn't had that predictability
of these schemes so they could invest
properly
um other plans to simplify these schemes
into something that consumers can
understand better uh and how can how
will you avoid a further scandal at the
Helms green deal scandal well I think uh
that's something that my colleague Grant
chaps is going to be announcing the
whole scheme I wanted to
announce the broader outlines of the
strategy a big push towards energy
Independence Renewables and nuclear a
big push towards Energy Efficiency with
this uh you know 12 billion pounds of
investment this Parliament and the next
so
um we we will be announcing a plan but
yes I want this to be a very
straightforward offer for families that
we're asking to take these measures
themselves
I want it to be very straightforward for
them to know exactly what they need to
do to improve their Energy Efficiency
and for families that we're helping
because they're on low incomes I want it
to be very straightforward for them to
know how we're going to help them yeah
many families just don't have the spare
cash right now and won't have for some
time to invest in that well that's one
of the reasons why we're putting so much
extra money into it okay
okay you mentioned the
notion of energy Independence uh EDF who
the government are working with in size
will see are French
that's not really UK Andy energy
Independence
well I let me be clear
um it's going to be a nuclear power
plant in Britain supplying the
equivalent of the power for that needed
by six million homes so
um I have absolutely no problem with
foreign ownership of some of our
national teams would you let me finish
of some of our Key Energy infrastructure
providing it is consistent with National
Security concerns and I have to get the
balance right but I think if we want to
move to energy Independence we should
welcome investment from the best
companies all over the world who can
help us do that okay where is the fuel
from for nuclear person Source strong
you'll have to ask nuclear experts on
that but I'll happily write to you with
some information what the UK is so
that's what Independence either
well um when I talk about independence
I'm not talking about
cutting ourselves off from the rest of
the world cutting ourselves off from our
friends and allies I think we have to
work together with fellow democracies to
deal with the fact that we have all
discovered that we are extremely
vulnerable
to what dictators like Putin do in
countries like Ukraine and we have to
work together to insulate ourselves from
those threats but that means working
closely with countries like Norway the
European Union the United States so that
we can deal with these challenges
together we really you're moving from
dependence
a mother or
that's not Independence well okay you
and I have different definitions of what
Independence is but uh I imagine I
appreciate that Independence is your
specialist chosen Topic in life
generally but when I'm talking about
energy Independence I'm talking about
making sure that our energy supplies
come from sources that we can trust and
that means nuclear generated in this
country it means Renewables and it means
where there are international flows from
friends and allies that we can trust
I go a little bit further on the the
issue of nuclear and size whale sea
that's not going to come on stream for
quite some time and you get very poor
record in delivering this when you
consider that Hinckley is already
significantly overdue and about 26
billion over budget
well I do think that we take too long to
deliver major infrastructure projects
that was the comment I made earlier and
we need to do what we can to improve
that track record although I think
actually other countries have similar
issues when they're delivering nuclear
power plants you'll hear about our
nuclear strategy when the business
secretary makes his announcement but
that's why Renewables are a very
important part of this plan as well
why was there no announcement in your
statements for example on increasing the
renewable capacity in Scotland and in
particular increasing funding to
projects like carbon capture and storage
in the Northeast the acorn project
because if that were taken off the
reserve list that could make a
significant impact
well we have
um
increased
our supply from Renewables by more than
any other large European country I think
we're second only to Germany in terms of
the total proportion of our energy that
comes Renewables about 40 percent so
it's a record that I'm very proud of
because this government has really
blazed a trail internationally
but is there more we can do absolutely
and you'll hear that from the business
secretary when he makes his announcement
will you take carbon capture and Storage
off the reserve list carbon capture and
storage is extremely important but if
you are asking me where I think the
biggest Gap in our strategy is at the
moment it's actually nuclear I think
we've we've done well on Renewables we
need to do even better but we need to
make more progress on nuclear much
additional cross for the winter bills
for individual Bill payers from
investment nuclear
well um the the whole purpose of this
plan is to reduce spills by giving
people plentiful access to cheap green
energy in time but we are very aware
that this is you know a decades-long
project we have a national ambition a
national promise a commitment to get to
Net Zero by 2050 and this is a very very
important part of that we'll add a levy
onto people's bills in London well we
have levies on people's bills at the
moment to pay for this transition and we
recognize that that's going to be one of
many ways it's also going to be
investment by taxpayers from Central
funds the size well C announcement is
about 700 million pounds of taxpayers
funds so there'll be funding from many
different sources
can I ask you a question is 1.7 billion
or 1.5 billion the larger figure
to that can you just explain why you're
asking it
so in this year's
this one he has identified
um 1.7 billion pounds
less because of inflationary pressures
you have said that the scripture will
get 1.5 billion over the next two years
and burn up consequentials well um the
truth is that every government
Department every devolved administration
every family actually in Scotland and
the whole of the UK is having to deal
with inflationary pressures that we face
and the number one thing we can do and
the number one thing we can do to help
John Swinney is to bring down those
inflationary pressures which is why I
hope that behind the scenes even if not
publicly you and he will welcome the
fact that we had a very strong package
of measures that the obr say is going to
reduce inflation to below what it would
have been because of the very difficult
decisions that we've taken so that's the
root cause but in the meantime we have
provided one and a half billion pounds
more for Scottish schools Scottish
hospitals or however you choose to spend
it because you have that decision under
the Barnet consequentials which we hope
will help Scotland and indeed the money
that we're giving to Wales and Northern
Ireland equally over the next two years
that doesn't help with this year's
shortfall on the budget caused by
inflation well everyone is facing those
pressures and I think the best thing we
can do to help you and to help all
government departments is to have a
credible plan to deal with the root
cause of that issue and that is bring
down inflation I also think it's the
case that the spending review settlement
LED means that this year compared to
last year there was a seven percent
increase in real terms in Scottish Amy
Library figures that I've seen that I
don't quite support that they see Cuts
in the budget in real terms
um the other part I just wanted to ask
very quickly chair was that same Johnson
City has asked for flexibility to move
money from the capital budget uh to the
resource budget is that something you're
going to agree to well I know you had a
meeting with the chief Secretary of the
Treasury and uh I look forward to
hearing the outcome of those discussions
on the subject of Energy Efficiency
Chancellor could you take away the
proliferation of accreditation schemes
for insulation and Energy Efficiency
installers there are so many of them and
that is what people say is leading to
the proliferation of poor installations
that people then lose confidence in
well thank you I mean obviously it's an
area you know a great deal about and I
will happily take that away and talk
about it to Grant chaps
I've got myself in four or five minutes
um
um
you've talked in the round about NHS and
education spending
um can you confirm that you feel that
the increases to both are going to be
sufficient to improve services in the
NHS but also Stave off the prospect of
Staffing cuts that head teachers are
predicting
well I hope so
um Amanda Pritchard the chief executive
of NHS England said that she believed
that the the package that we announced
for the NHS and social care should be
enough to deal with uh the pressures
that she's facing
um the campaigners for schools ahead of
the Autumn statement were saying that
they believed they needed two billion
pounds which actually the ifs confirms
restores funding in schools to above
2010 levels per head so I very much hope
so you can find can I can I therefore
move this on to defense in your Autumn
statement you you did not commit to
increase defense spending
um why was that
well we did say very clearly
um that both I and the Prime Minister
believe that defense spending needs to
increase we recognize the very real
pressures my views on this are obviously
in the public domain because I was on
the back benches and I talked about my
strong belief that we need to increase
uh defense spending as a proportion of
GDP so I think my views on that are on
the record but I think it's very
important when you're responsible for
taxpayers funds to know what it is that
you're buying and we have this process
that you will be very aware of called
the integrated review
it LEDs to the largest sustained
increase of funding 16 billion pounds
from memory since the Cold War when it
was announced by the then prime minister
Boris Johnson
and that was written though before
Ukraine and so I think we need to go
through a process to update that but I
was very clear in My Autumn statement
this was not pushing things to the right
I wanted that process to become complete
ahead of the spring budget
you think I mean your views are on the
record as are a number of other
ministers including the defense bench
but do you think there's a general
acceptance within government
um at the very core of government that
given events in Ukraine given events
um in geopolitical events generally it's
it's an increasingly unstable world out
there that there is a value in
increasing defense spending on a
sustainable basis
if only to act as a deterrence
um
um because that war is very expensive at
the end of the day
yes I do
um and I also believe having been
foreign secretary for a year
that it's one of the biggest ways that
Britain can make a contribution to
Global peace and prosperity because we
have absolutely superb Armed Forces
respected throughout the world second
largest military in NATO
and uh hugely experienced Armed Forces
who've been involved in conflicts in
Iraq Afghanistan
Bosnia and so on so I think there's a
very important contribution that we can
make as a global citizen in defending
democracy open societies and the rule of
law and final question if I may
um hard power very important but so is
soft power
um as you well know have a former
foreign secretary work at the British
Council the BBC World Service and so
forth invaluable in in promoting
understanding and Trust over time
um
could I make a plea that you continue
with that Focus as well now as
Chancellor given the importance of of
soft power in in trying to avoid the use
of hard power at the end of the day the
two come as a team but you always tried
the soft power first
well David Cameron used to use the
phrase that we're a soft power
superpower and I do think it's something
where we we have enormous
cultural reach around the world and uh
you know it's
it's very important in terms of
Britain's role as a Force for good in
the world so I absolutely recognize the
case you're making thank you thank you
John Danny thanks very much um earlier
in the session you mentioned that eight
billion pounds it's going into Health
and Social care and you stressed the
importance of getting good value for
money from that um and I think you said
the way to do that is through real
public service reform so I'm very
pleased to hear that because I think one
of the perhaps the only tragedy of the
brexit years was the uh the loss of
focus on public service reform which had
preceded 2016. I mean the the government
that you were part of it under David
Cameron said a whole train of reforms in
in place
I'd like to see a return to that can you
just flesh out what you think what you
mean by public service reform I mean you
mentioned Patricia Hewitt delighted to
draw on the expertise of of the Blair
era uh but what do you think she's going
to be what are you tasking her to do and
crucially do you agree with me that the
the great objective should be to reduce
Demand on the state rather than just
improve the efficiency of the supply and
how do we achieve that well I think it's
right to start with the NHS because
that's the biggest single area where we
can see demand going up because of an
aging population new medicines coming on
stream you know very big pressures
um but there's also the biggest
opportunity and
um
the real heart of that is actually to
move to prevention rather than cure to
tackle diseases Upstream if you diagnose
a cancer at stage one or two it's much
cheaper than stage three or four and
patient is much more likely to live so
all sorts of reasons why you would want
to do that
the pandemic obviously meant the NHS had
to focus on an immediate priority to
make sure people with covid got the
life-saving treatment they need and
we're incredibly grateful to them for
what they did
actually public service reform did
continue because Matt Hancock as health
secretary piloted the Health and Care
Bill through the House of Commons and
the integrated care boards it's a
technical name but that basically is
designed to bring together Health and
Care Systems locally so they can focus
on prevention and not cure
the reason that the health sector and I
asked Patricia Hewitt to do this review
is because she's actually running one of
those integrated care boards in Norfolk
and Waverley she's obviously very
experienced as a former Health secretary
and we wanted to make sure these new
local nhs's work and she's very
committed to tackling waste and
inefficiency and to making sure that we
empower
local NHS is in the same way that we
Empower heads of schools to be creative
use their freedoms to really make change
happen on the ground I have a concern
that I've
you know is no secret because I've
written about it publicly many times
that we have more Targets in the NHS
than any other healthcare system in the
world I think that actually stops the
NHS being efficient
and so I'm hoping that Patricia Hewitt's
review will help us to move in the right
direction I mean I completely applaud
the ambition of the of the icbs and the
idea not in integrating but localizing
that Health and Social care system is
absolutely right so thank you for that
um just just lastly
on education or more broadly skills and
Welfare
major priority here I mean do you not
agree that in order a to save money into
great value for taxpayer and deliver the
transition that we need
you know we mentioned integration uh
installers and so on we need a skills
Revolution you've you've set out your
ambition on that isn't a part of the
answer to that to radically reduce he in
this country we should discuss we are
spending too much on putting too many
young people through University we need
to be investing much more well maybe
taking some of that budget out and
returning it to taxpayers but balancing
much more towards Fe and Vocational
skills I don't look at it in quite that
binary way I think he is one of our
great success stories I think we have
fantastic universities I think the
number 50 of school leavers who go to
university on the whole get a very good
education in the systems in which in in
this country I'm concerned about the 50
who don't so I would say the way I would
phrase what you've just said is I would
rather I'd like to see the same
revolution in quality in Effie that
we've had in he and I would like to know
that every single one of our school
leavers leaves with the skill levels
necessary to get a decent wage and make
contribution into modern dynamic economy
it won't surprise you to know that I'm
concerned that isn't the case at the
moment and that's why I commissioned a
lot of work in the Autumn statement to
try and work out I don't what I don't
want to do is another big review I think
we've had very good reviews we've got
very good policies in place like T
levels lifelong learning entitlements
boot camps the white paper but I want to
understand you know in the end put all
these things together
and are we going to be giving our young
people the same skills that they were
getting
Germany or Japan and if not what do we
need to do to change it
you so much Danny Angela thank you very
much Chancellor um this year alone your
party has given us three prime ministers
four chancellors four different versions
of a conservative government and six
fiscal events
147 members of the government including
32 cabinet ministers have resigned or
been sacked what effect do you think
this chaos has had on our economic
prospects and our International
reputation
well I wish we hadn't had that level of
instability
um but
um I produced an Autumn statement that
is designed to restore economic
stability and consistency of economic
policy making and I hope we can turn the
page on all that instability
but it had a detrimental effect hasn't
it well it's you know it's it's not
something anyone would wish for but I
would say that um
if you look at what the obr is saying if
you look at what the oecd is saying the
primary cause for the economic
challenges we Face are the two big
shocks of a pandemic and an energy
crisis that's what other countries are
facing as well there are you know
Germany Holland Italy has higher
inflation than we have so I think it's
wrong to say that this is somehow a
uniquely UK issue in terms of the
economic instability everyone accepts
that there are economic shocks around
but doesn't that mean it's an even more
silly time to be a self-indulgent as
we've seen in governance your party
deliver at that crucial time when there
are these shocks well as I say I wish we
hadn't had that instability but I think
it's wrong to say that the economic
issues that we're dealing with are
primarily as a result of that I think
that uh you know if you look at this
year and I've just counseled against
taking one year snapshots but you just
talked about all the instability we've
had in one year that happens to be the
year where we've got the fastest growth
in the G7 so that's why I would hesitate
to draw too many comparisons right so
you're possibly arguing that we should
do this every year or as a growth
I'll be pleased to know I'm not arguing
it
um it wasn't mentioned in the Autumn
statement but you've retained a plan cut
in the surcharge on Bank profit down for
down percent to
two percent and that constitutes an 18
billion band giveaway to the banks over
the next five years at a time when
Rising interest rates will make them
more profitable
um do you think that as real living
standards are set to plummet by seven
percent in the next two years that this
is a fair choice that you've made
yes and I'll tell you why because I made
a decision in the Autumn statement that
I was not going to do things as far as I
could possibly avoid it but damage
economic growth what banks are paying
and the reason for that change in the
rate is because we are at the same time
increasing corporation tax from 19 to 25
if you add in the three percent
surcharge they are paying higher profits
are they uh if you add in the surcharge
as it is they are paying higher marginal
rates on their profits than in other
European countries and so I don't want
them to move their operations out of
London I want them to contribute
continue to contribute to the exchequer
because I want them to help fund the NHS
and schools and all the very important
public services that we want
okay so to date um
today's bill as well 50 MPS on your own
side have signed a hostile Amendment to
the leveling up Bill which is being
discussed
um on the floor of the house which would
abolish mandatory house building targets
and the government appears to be backing
down from putting those targets into
position
um this has been dubbed by the author of
the Tory Manifesto in 2019 that
destroyed the planning system to make
the recession worse Amendment
so what you're going to face down the
rebels in order to help growth or
are you going to give in to them and if
you give in how can you
claim that the government can make the
right decisions for our economy and
tackle the housing shortage if it's not
going to stand up to this kind of
pressure
well this is Michael goes policy area so
I can't tell you
um exactly what his decision is going to
be with respect to specific amendments
to the leveling up Bill but what I can
say is that we are very aware of the
difficulty that young people have
getting onto the housing ladder and we
are also very aware of shortcomings in
the planning system and I think the the
root problem that is chancellor have to
look at
is the way that incentives are not
aligned across the planning system
and I think that we do need to ask
ourselves why it is that the way our
planning rules work often sets local
communities against the national need to
build more houses and how we can improve
that and that's certainly something that
I'll be looking at does the treasurer
assess the impact on economic growth of
lower housing suppliers a result of the
scrapping of targets if that were water
were to happen we're not just aware of
the impact on economic growth we're also
aware on the of the impact on thousands
of young people if they can't get onto
the housing ladder or move to where the
jobs might be indeed in a reasonable way
so are you doing that assessment we we
are always keeping that under review
it's a very very important part of
macroeconomic policy now um I want to
ask a question about the cost of the um
bulb bailout because the obr has
reported that the cost of bailing out
bulb energy is now a colossal 6.5
billion pounds which is more than 200
pounds per UK household there's very
little available information on that and
in fact we were erroneously given
um a cost here and asked not to publish
it a couple of months back that cost was
4 billion it's now gone up to 6.5
billion so how are these losses made up
and are you expecting them to go any
higher and why on Earth is there so much
secrecy about it or rather than giving
you a second uh piece of erroneous
information can I write to you and give
you more detailed information on that I
appreciate it's a very important issue
yeah
um I wanted to ask about
um about fuel Duty and vehicle exercise
taxes because we've just had a a and in
fact the chair has written to you about
this letter that was published the the
minute this session started in your in
the Treasure's response to the jobs
growth and productivity after
coronavirus report it stated that the
Autumn statement brought forward
measures to fight Rising costs for
households and businesses such as
freezing fuel duty but actually
um the obr told us that they had taken
account of the end of that freeze and
also
costed in as part of their forecast the
proposed 12 Pence increase in fuel Duty
which will be due in April so it's now
completely unclear what the government's
policy on fuel duty is you've given us 2
versions one in which the freeze and you
freeze it and that carries on but you've
costed six billion pounds for the cost
of actually raising it by 12 Pence what
which is it well the obr is independent
so they make assumptions based on what
they believe will happen that's their
job constitutionally we want them to be
independent but the truth is that
field juices are frozen for this year
until the end of March and we will
announce our decision as to what's going
to happen next year at the next budget
and I can't tell you what that decision
is now because it hasn't been made
because I don't know what the economic
situation will be when it comes to the
next budget but we will make that
decision in the way that chancellors
always make that decision in the spring
budget but just to be clear if you are
going to freeze fuel duties going
forwards that's going to be six billion
pounds you're going to have to find
that's the cost I think that is about
the right number yes
chosen to raise taxes by freezing income
tax thresholds rather than raising the
rates and you talked about that in
answer to an earlier question and this
has been called the stealth tax the
so-called stealth tax analysis shows
that this hits middle earners harder the
resolution Foundation demonstrated that
someone earning 62 000 pounds a year for
example loses as much from these
threshold freezers as someone who earns
124
000 that's 1 600 pounds but for the
lower earner as a percentage of their
earnings it's twice as much as for the
higher earner is this your definition of
fairness well I think you have to
avoid taking individual measures from
the budget and not look at the context
of all the measures taken together so
for higher earners we did some very
specific things reducing the Threshold
at which the 45p rate is payable by 25
000 pounds that means anyone earning
over 150
000 pounds is going to pay a thousand
pounds more tax next year and the
distributional analysis shows that
people on Lower incomes benefit most
from the measures the decisions that I
took
but I did decide yes that I would prefer
to do this through extending for two
more years the freeze on thresholds that
increasing the headline rates because
over time when we can afford to I'd like
to reduce those headline rates and so I
didn't want to go in the opposite
direction but the one thing I would say
is
amongst my many failings to say that I
increased tax stealthily is not one I
think you can you can really say I've
been completely open with people that
taxes went up by 25 billion pounds as a
result of the Autumn statement and I
spelled out very clearly where that was
happening I suppose with inflation
rising at that kind of level uh fiscal
drag is worse people get dragged into
higher rates of tax in in their millions
and and many would say even though
you've said that taxes are rising that
it's not obvious at what which stage
they're going to flip from the one to
the other uh so understand that but also
over the in this forecast or the obr
forecast they actually have inflation
going into negative territory
so I think towards the end of the period
relatively many fewer people are dragged
into the higher ends and just on the
personal Taxi particularly the personal
allowance and the primary threshold I
mean the primary threshold had a very
significant increase in July this year
so it was about nine and a half thousand
and it went up to twelve thousand five
hundred and seventy but also if you look
over the period since 2010 because the
personal allowances been doubled
um and this increase in the primary
threshold actually even by the end of
the forecast period so 2027-28
um someone earning 28 000 pounds will
still be paying 870 pounds less income
tax and National Insurance than had we
had both thresholds just risen by
inflation since 2010 yeah so there's a
get that clarified
um exactly yeah thank you very much
Angela and thank you last but by no
means least Andrea thanks thank you
Chancellor do you approve of
retrospective taxation
in general no and so do you think that
the windfall taxes on electricity
generators and um also offshore offshore
energy firms is retrospective
well
um I don't want to say something that's
inaccurate so I will write you with a
precise answer to that question but can
I tell you how I approach those windfall
taxes more generally so
I believe that they raise about 54
billion pounds
um I think that's a reasonable
contribution given that this year alone
we're spending 80 billion pounds to
support people with their energy bills I
am absolutely against windfall taxes
that aren't real windfalls in other
words an unexpected increase in profits
because I don't want to deter investment
but in the case of
electricity generators the the
tax that we introduced the 45p tax that
we introduced on that is when they are
getting more than 75 pounds per megawatt
hour which is 50 more than the average
cost of electricity over the last decade
so it's much higher than they would have
expected when they made their events I
completely understand that sorry to cut
you off but the time is very short and I
do understand that do you suspect that
it will reduce investment in energy
infrastructure in the UK either from the
offshore energy companies or from the
electricity generators I very much hope
not because you know our oil and gas
industry employs 116 000 people of more
than a third of them in Scotland they
are very important part of our
transition to Net Zero and what was your
expectation in in the statement did you
just think well we need the money so so
be it or or did you talk to the industry
before making this decision if you
um if you uh your starting point has to
be if you don't want to deter investment
that this has to be fairly designed in a
way that is genuinely taxing uh the
profits that people weren't expecting to
make as a result of a sudden surge in
global prices and the way this has been
structured is that if you invest you
don't have to pay these mineral taxes
you get 91 pence in the pound back and
if it's a decarbonization project 109
back so you actually get more than you
spend so that's investment allowance
doesn't apply to the electricity
generators does it the electricity
generators I think the key thing is that
most large-scale new Renewables and
nuclear Investments are under contracts
for difference and if you're within the
contracts for difference uh scheme you
would not be subject to the energy
generators Levy so it really applies to
a subset of Investments which took place
under the Renewables obligation so under
contracts for difference already if
there is the government commits to make
good uh yeah the price I know how it
works sorry I know how it works but
nevertheless those electricity
generators could presumably offset that
tax liability by investing in new
renewable projects under cfds in the UK
but you're not giving them the
investment allowance for for corporation
tax which they will pay in addition to
this they'll be able to write off their
Investments as they they they normally
do but for the new energy generators let
me know they won't
okay
um moving on in terms of um energy
suppliers that those supplying to
Consumers and businesses
um what plans if any do you have for
requiring them to offer fixed-rate
prices to Consumers at the moment as
you'll know very few do and they would
argue that it's partly due to the
collapse of energy suppliers that they
can't afford to because those costs can
hit them unexpectedly so is there not a
virtuous circle of treating them like
Banks requiring them to have Capital
requirements and also requiring them to
offer fixed rate term prices to
Consumers and businesses to enable them
to better manage their cash flows there
may be and we are looking at the way the
whole energy Market functions because it
obviously hasn't been functioning in the
way that we would want we've had some
huge external shocks
you know some huge bills event landed at
the doors of taxpayers as a result
um and and I appreciate the scenario you
know a great deal about and we're very
happy to engage with you as to the
reforms that the energy Market needs
okay well it certainly it certainly
seems to me that there isn't evidence a
speed of decision making coming on some
of these critical areas that we have
just paid in Spades in our economy as a
result of a failing energy Market not
least of which is quick decisions on
planning do we want
grid overhead or underground for example
and it does seem to me that the Autumn
statement is spending billions and
billions of pounds that wouldn't have
been necessary have we taken those
decisions earlier
um well um
that may be a fair criticism but what I
would say is that we're trying in the
Autumn statement to show what the
solution is and the solution is to move
faster on nuclear and Renewables
to encourage Energy Efficiency but also
and this is all going to be set up by
the business secretary very soon to look
at the fundamental reforms that we need
in the energy Market going forward
because uh you know I I recognize the
case you make that it hasn't been
operating in the way that it needs to
yeah just to completely change the
subject in terms of how to make our
economy more productive so on the growth
side there's such a dearth of women
coming back into the workplace as a
result of primary Child Care
responsibilities it is so difficult to
find good child care and to be able to
afford good child care so what is what
are we doing from a productivity point
of view to get more good women back into
the workplace and secondly I have to ask
you the question investment in human
potential in the early years in actually
getting those families well established
so that we don't see so much family
breakdown that has such devastating
consequences on Tiny children who then
go on to not be school ready what are
you doing in the treasury to think about
investing in human potential and the
quality of getting women back into our
economy
well when I delivered the Autumn
statement I'd only been Chancellor for
five weeks and so I won't pretend that I
was able to get to the bottom I'll give
you another five weeks thank you and
then I didn't think it would be much
longer um but I I won't pretend that I
was able to get to the bottom of those
issues but what um on both of those
things
um I pointed a direction of travel so
um you know on the skills agenda I have
asked for some root and Branch help in
understanding if we really are equipping
all our young people with the skills
they need I don't believe that will just
be about further education I think a lot
of the issues set in earlier than that
and people leave Primary School unable
to read and write properly and often
that's because of problems they had
before they went to primary school so I
accept the argument on which you've been
campaigning very effectively for many
years and your other point was about
women Healthcare so child care I I
accept there is a big issue there and
um as part of melstrid's review into
Workforce participation we will
absolutely be looking at child care
issues because
um uh well you're right to highlight the
problems yeah but it's a growth strategy
it's a growth strategy to get you know
there's something we one one in five
Enterprises is is largely dominated by
men that means four in five of the
potential other workers who could be
generating taxes for the ex-chequeror
simply not there it's not happening to
them well it's not just a growth
strategy It's actually an anti-inflation
strategy because also the inability to
get the labor that you need to grow your
business is something that ends up with
people having to pay more and charge
their customers more so um I couldn't
agree with you more it's a very very big
issue thank you
thank you very much Andrea and uh thank
you Chancellor I appreciate that this is
your first time in front of the
committee that you've been in the this
chair in the health committee for many
years so
um it's uh it's it's funny to see how
these tables turn isn't it
um but um you've made your number of
different commitments to write to us
with follow-up information and we'll go
through the transcript and make sure
that we follow up with you
um so that we get the replies to those
things that you've committed to send us
and then my final commitment that I'm
going to try and get out of you is that
we heard that the from the office of
budget responsibility yesterday that
it's written into law that their
forecasts get published alongside a
budget and there's a commitment to do
two of these a year now this word mini
budget and fiscal event and so on has
really entered the language in order to
get around that commitment will you
commit as Chancellor to you know
obviously absent a major emergency like
a pandemic and requiring you to make
School changes but as a general rule
will you can be committing to do those
two events a year alongside an office
for Budget responsibility report yes
thank you
chair can I just special please can I
apologize to the members and to you
Chancellor for stepping out of this
meeting I'm chair of the all-party group
for children with short lives and our
ijm we heard from Sophie whose daughter
Isabel is 10 and doesn't have much
longer to live and she will not be able
to have her hydrotherapy sessions in the
pool in her garden because of the cost
of energy would you meet people from the
appg for children with short lives to
discuss the specific problems they're
experiencing I'm very happy to but I
think it might be important for the
health secretary to meet so let me talk
to you offline about which one of the
two of us will be most able to help you
coach
and thank you Chancellor thank you Dan
order order that concludes the treasury
committee's evidence session
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended